clic clic waouh tu fais hyper bien le
clic merci à toi ça lui a tout salut à
tous aujourd'hui on se retrouve pour une
vidéo un peu spéciale puisque
aujourd'hui je suis enjoy phoenix or
c'est faux que sendaï jardin dix ans
j'étais même pas des bises etc non non
c'est moi alors aujourd'hui vidéo un peu
spécial non vidéo un peu normal c'est là
que je vais faire ma 19e séances de
détatouage au laser jusqu'ici normal
alors quand même oui
deux petites particularités la première
c'est qu'aujourd'hui je la teste sans
pommade anesthésiante puisque cette
dernière technologie
je l'avais testé qu'avec donc là ce coup
là on va voir ce que ça donne 100
pommade avec une station à lille et ses
jantes et la deuxième particularité et
ben je ne vous spoile pas vous verrez à
la fin de la vidéo
voilà c'est ma petite surprise allait en
fils
[Musique]
passez vite deux mois la dernière fois
c'était l'été là c'est l'automne la
prochaine fois ce sera l'hiver s'est
rafraîchi non
vous voilà donc le petit débrief alors
on n'est pas immédiatement après je vais
pas vous mentir parce que j'avais des
trucs à faire mes petits débris quand
même vous avez vu c'est en somme toute
assez classique à ceci près donc que
cette fois je n'avais pas de pommade
anesthésiant comme j'en avais vu avec
pendant les onze premières séances avec
le pico jour est donc alors ça donne
quoi je pense que vous l'avez constaté
vous même sur les sur les images je fais
un petit peu moins le malin que
d'habitude
et vraiment ça m'a rappelé des bons
souvenirs du tout premier centre avec le
laser du switch quand je faisais toutes
mes séances cul sec
vraiment c'était vraiment un bonheur
[Musique]
alors ceci dit pour est complètement
transparent avec vous ça fait quand même
moins mal que qu'à l'époque alors pour à
mon avis pour deux raisons d'abord parce
que le laser que j'utilise maintenant le
plus beau jour il est censé il est
réputé être moins douloureux parce
qu'ils chauffent moins voilà parce que
l'effet est moins thermique que
mécanique c'est à dire qu'ils brûlent
moins mais il cogne plus sur le sur le
pigment tout cas c'est ce qui le fait
qu'il est censé faire et justement le
pigment ben j'en ai beaucoup moins qu'à
l'époque donc la douleur c'est un peu la
couleur de la peau donc là il y en a
moins et c'est aussi le pigment lancre
qui explose sous là sous la peau comme à
l'époque y en a eu beaucoup
et que maintenant il y en a quand même
moi mais ça on va parler à la fin ben ça
fait moins mal forcément donc moins
douloureux qu'à l'époque mais quand même
plus douloureux que avec la pommade
anesthésiant alors du coup la pommade
anesthésiante ça me donne l'occasion
d'un temps parlé un petit peu
qu'est ce que c'est et comment ça
fonctionne alors là la composition
d'abord le truc tout bête c'est une peau
mate qui contient deux choses d'abord de
la lidocaïne qui est un produit qui est
très connue parce qu'il est très
couramment utilisé notamment en
injection pour faire des anesthésies
locales
vous en avez peut-être même déjà eu et
si on vous a retiré un petit grain de
beauté ou fait une suture un truc comme
ça ce qu'on vous injecte autour des
plaies pour tout ça c'est très souvent
de la lidocaine donc là c'est pas en
forme injectable c'est en sous forme de
pommade et cette pommade
elle contient aussi de l'april aux
canines qui est un autre anesthésiant
local qui est beaucoup moins utilisé le
voir pas du tout utilisé en injectable
en europe mais dans d'autres pays oui
mais en tout cas c'est aussi un
anesthésiant local
dans les deux cas comment ça fonctionne
ça bloque l'influx nerveux
c'est à dire que ça empêche vos nerfs de
transmettre l'information de la douleur
ça et quand votre corps reçoit une
agression bayard une espèce de système
d' alerte qui se met en route qu'il ya
attention la vie à quelque chose de pas
bien qui se passe il faut faire quelque
chose pour que ça s'arrête
et ce système d'alarmé c'est la douleur
là on bloque le bloc le signal alarmant
mais un truc sur la cloche ça ne sonne
pas où ça sonne moins fort parce que on
sent quand même un petit peu
alors concrètement maintenant cette
pommade gelé déjà un petit peu expliqué
dans les épisodes précédents mais en
gros il faut tartiner la zone a à
traiter
là en l'occurrence tout le tout la
superficie du tatouage avec une bonne
couche épaisse de crème qu'il faut
ensuite
recouvrir avec un pansement spéciale qui
est un pansement transparent qui est
étanche surtout pourquoi pas d'abord
parce que saïfi cuite la crème reste
bien bien au contact de la de la peau et
de la zone à traiter
et puis ensuite bas ça permet surtout de
pouvoir continuer à bouger parce que il
faut le laisser agir minimum une heure
un minimum c'est-à-dire vous mettez la
pommade une heure au moins avant le
rendez-vous de laser donc c'est quand
même bien de pouvoir se servir d'eux du
membre que vous voulez vous faire
détatouer pendant ce temps la victime en
l'occurrence la fesse je m'en sers peu
sauf que là je marche je mets un
pantalon et c'est donc
donc couches épaisses pansements
transparent bien étanche qui garde la
crème en place et puis au bout d'une
heure minimum on retire un petit coup de
compresses et l'a1 l'anesthésique de
surface elle reste efficace qu'on en une
heure ou deux au juste petit disque les
moeurs faites attention si vous avez la
peau abîmée pour une raison x ou y
il faut pas mettre de pommade à des
expédients dessus voilà c'est une ce
qu'on appelle une contre indication donc
bah si par exemple c'est vous êtes dans
le même cas que moi c'est à dire un
détatouage prenez soin de la zone qu'on
va vous des tatoués parce que si elle
est abîmée ben vous pourrez pas vous
pourrez pas mettre deux premières
d'anesthésiant de ce serait quand même
dommage
alors on parle et d'injection il faut
savoir qu'il ya certains centres de
détatouage qui pratiquent la nive teddy
local avec des injections
c'est un petit peu à chacun de voir
l'anesthésié l'injection elle est censée
être plus profonde
mais par contre il ya les piqûres
là où on vous fait pas d'anesthésié pour
vous avez cédé avant la piqûre qui va
vous faire un essai dis donc il ya la
piqûre qui fait un peu mal va pas se
mentir
après du coup ça fait vraiment mon sens
je n'ai jamais fait personnellement mais
pour connaître un peu ce genre de le
d'anesthésié je pense que vraiment le
laser ne le sont pas du tout alors que
dans le cas de la pommade
on ne sent rien quand on met la pommade
évidemment c'est complètement indolore
par contre après mon sens un tout petit
peu le laser mais franchement voilà à
titre personnel pour la surface que j'ai
à me faire détatouer je pense que les
deux trois minutes de picotement léger
que je ressens c'est moins douloureux
que les piqûres qu'on aurait me faire
pour me faire lundi
donc je préfère la peau mate ou non ça
me va très bien comme ça après c'est du
cas par cas
en tout cas un truc est sûre à moi que
vous aimiez tout ce qui est douleur et
souffrance c'est votre choix je ne juge
pas insister pour avoir une anesthésie
avant vos séances de détatouage
franchement pour avoir connu les deux
y'a pas y'a pas photo donc logiquement
c'est un médecin qui va vous faire les
séances de détatouage ou mouvements
certains médecins de recevoir la
première fois n'hésitez pas si vous le
propose pas spontanément a demandé ce
qu'ils vous fassent une ordonnance pour
que vous puissiez aller chercher à la
pharmacie de la pommade anesthésiante
c'est mon petit conseil vous faites
comme vous voulez commente encore une
fois tout ce qu il est un peu moins bon
ceci étant dit on arrive à là on arrive
on est à la dix neuvième séance
est ce que vous vous demandez et j'ai
cru constater dans les commentaires que
vous étiez un petit peu moqueur jeu
vous en veux pas c'est de bonne guerre
vous êtes un petit peu moqueur sur
l'efficacité de ce laser
voilà donc venu le moment du riz ville
donc voilà à quoi ressemblait mon
tatouage avant la séance d'il ya deux
mois
voilà ça ressemblait à ça ressemble à ça
donc donc même déjà pas mal voilà à quoi
ressemblait un tatouage
avant cette séance là donc c'est à dire
deux mois plus tard à l on fait moins
les malins sa rivale mans elle a tout de
suite ah ouais ouais c'est vrai ça
fonctionne ça fonctionne quand même pas
pour mémoire je vous remets côte à côte
le tatouage juste après le balma séance
chez le tatoueur
c'est à dire hier presque trois ans
maintenant mon anniversaire est le
tatouage bas du jour la côte à côte
vous voyez que ça fonctionne alors oui
ça va bientôt faire trois ans parce que
j'ai commencé les séances plus tôt en
février
donc ça va bientôt faire 3 ans de
traitement mais ça fonctionne on fera
les comptes à la fin parce que c'est une
question qu'on me pose beaucoup à filmer
combien ça coûte finalement bas c'est à
la fin de la foire qu'on compte les
bouses et c'est à la fin du concert
qu'on paie les musiciens
et tout un tas de problèmes de ce type
donc je vous propose de faire un petit
calcul à la fin alors ce sera quand bas
ce sera pas aujourd'hui
en tout cas c'est sûr puisque j'ai un
d'ores et déjà rendez-vous en 2020 pour
pour la prochaine séance
ça sera peut-être la dernière n'est
peut-être pas mais en tout cas on est
vraiment très clairement plus proche de
la fin que du début
donc je vous donne rendez-vous en 2020
pour parler de pourparlers de mes fesses
et de nombreux tatouages
évidemment ici là il y aura d'autres
vidéos sur d'été c'est donc ce que je
vous propose c'est d'ici là mettez vous
bien et surtout portez vous bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]